what's going on reject nation greg and
john here so we're actually going to
upload a different video at this time
about
the first look of mechagodzilla and
godzilla gone bad of the reason why
revealed did a reaction to that but i
just knew that if we put that up we
would get flooded with comments about
this new trailer that just dropped
so i was like let's just cover this one
first and we'll put that other one up
in like an hour and a half to two hours
later this one
i think is like two tv spots combined to
make one full
minute long video so let's see what's in
store peeps
and of course we'll talk about it
afterwards maybe go through some frames
and all that jazz you know how we do
zooming on the ears interesting
[Music]
dude that's a great shot
all right play that second one now
someone interpret that
[Music]
giant
oh we gotta go back through that
damn that was legit oh it's getting to
the point where i'm like are they
starting to show too much my god
but i just keep eating it up anyway i
mean at worst we'll have seen
all of one sequence or two but it is
so many cool shots i know i wasn't
expecting that many
especially towards the last half of the
other one there's so many new ones
let's go through this instead of going
to the very beginning we're just going
to start first here man there's a lot of
hot stuff
so this is millie bobby brown's
character saying
the line from the music uh in the actual
official trailer here we go
it was composed directly for this movie
i wonder if this is from the navy spot
moment
it looks like it's probably where the
apex group is they're right back here
like that looks like the mechagodzilla
design looks like they could be feel
free to correct us on anything we get
wrong i've heard theories about
the in skull island you might get to the
point where you can get to the
hollow earth in the way how they talked
about in king of the monsters how that's
how godzilla's been able to travel
and then now you can get that here with
skull island and this might be
linking towards how he gets the the kong
axe
maybe that's the moment here i mean this
doesn't look like regular skull island
it looks like something out of a fantasy
or something so yeah i mean maybe that's
the entryway or
something that we haven't seen yet i
mean if you look at the godzilla king of
the monsters credits i mean it seems
pretty clear they want us to be aware
that this is coming okay and this looks
like a completely different moment
yeah right here i mean maybe after the
city fight maybe they like take it out
to the sea again
why would you do that why would you be
by the sea at night if you think
godzilla is attacking you
at night where you're most vulnerable
this looks out of like the first
godzilla movie
alexander skarsgard my new favorite
human character
so much connection with this girl who we
now know is called gia
right here in this shot just don't hurt
him don't hurt him this battle
is gonna be nuts yeah and i'm glad they
still have that you know human scale
like they're doing a lot more aerials
and stuff like
that but to at least get that like very
pov like how horrifying this would be
kind of shy
so is monarch like an official brand now
that they have like a water bottle here
water they got energy drinks they got
vitamins
i love this shot yeah damn look at that
shot
obviously okay so this is gonna be like
in the finale battle moment the way how
it's been in the last couple movies
with godzilla especially of how there's
a fight between titans and then the
humans are
kind of helping out to the point where
you're like i don't really need you to
cut to them i don't really need them to
be involved
but they're kind of doing something you
know i have that orca device that you
know it does something to some of the
monsters so okay
but this looks like in this scene where
they're flying around in some type of
jet
yeah you know because the monarch people
are always more than just scientists
they're also able to do like militaries
experts and maybe then they'll follow
kong or something into skull into the
hollow earth after that because you see
those jets those planes in those shots
too
you know those like spaces exactly ships
oh right here
okay in this shot i don't know where
they're at is that the monarch symbol or
the apex symbol it looks like the apex
that is yeah okay it is it looks over
here like there's a creature here yeah
is that the skull is that the guidera
skull
all right hold on a sec guys okay so
this is it terribly brightened up
yeah i can't tell if we're looking at
like you know his snout pointed towards
the door
and you know the the back of his just
spiky head
on the left side why would it just be
out there that must just be some room
they got
on a high shelf where no one can reach
no i bet this is when they're
discovering mechagodzilla or
ghidorah there is a mecca ghidorah yeah
i mean
i wouldn't put it that positive i mean
with the with the post-credits singing
king and the monsters at least it felt
like they're alluding to their building
mechagadora so that might be mecca
mechagadora it looks like they went into
the actual facility where all this is
happening
you can't imagine they'll just take that
head for a trophy they probably want to
use it these
shots damn that is brutal this is not
come out
such an amazing bro oh my god
uh so kong is down godzilla's on top of
him
oh look bigger as kong's head is i mean
godzilla is a a
thick beast but also he's got a tiny
little head that is
such a beautiful shot i'm in love with
that shot oh and i'm in love with that
[ __ ] should i mean the clash of the two
lightings the orange and the blue
yes okay so i get it they were zooming
in on her ear because she's
is she deaf i thought she was just doing
sign language because that was her way
of communicating with kong
yeah i don't know maybe it's like she
can sense his frequency or something
like that too
i mean i'm loving all the new footage
for it i mean if i had if i had a
one complaint about everything that's
been happening with the footage
and maybe this is an accurate
representation of the film of
godzilla's gone bad and there's reasons
why i could see why godzilla went bad in
the last movie with him
they do have the tease the good thing is
on our side for now that's like the last
line before they go to credits
when i'm also thinking about how they
nuked him
when he was in his home they also blew
up his home so i could see how he has
issues with the humans yeah you helped
but also hurt and you only helped out of
your own interests
yeah that's because they said it would
take a few years for him to recover
yeah and they were like no we need him
now because we messed up we nuked him
first and now he's unconscious and he
has to heal now we got to re-nuke him
again
i kind of just wish the marketing
whether you're on team kong or team
godzilla i just wish the marketing was a
little bit more
equal at least in the sense of not
having you kind of be like oh
kong's the underdog but we should root
for him to win because a lot of times
the marketing is making me feel like i
have to root for kong
if this was my marketing i would have
done it like i'd do a kong
spot and a godzilla spot and make each
one make a mystery around it is godzilla
the instigator is kong the instigator
make you know because there are two
sides of every story so
you know make yeah one look like the
antagonist in one and
vice versa in the other yeah but as it
stands i'm still so excited for this
movie you can't
wait for it leave your thoughts down
below you can subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
keep a lookout for the other video we're
gonna cover
last but not least
robert gunderson robert my friend
recently caught up with you and my dude
my dude has graduated in his
job to now being a car salesman damn
and you know what mr carzilla mr
carter skull that's stupid mr carr of
the the monsters
mecca mobile oh that's even better
that's the best one
i'm in need of a new car i desperately
am
you don't know the problems my car's had
over the years my car has a lot of
character
but it's a time i let it just move on to
the afterlife
but at the same time my friend has been
saying how he wants to possibly get into
streaming and doing his own gaming types
of videos and dude i highly encourage
you to do so your last name is gundersen
the gunderson channel dude that sounds
like the best kind of gaming channel
there is so
go for it man thank you for being part
of our patreon page dude
so happy to have you here congrats on
your new job start up that channel let
me know when you do
take care buddy